it's so funny in the proposal the scene
of you when you both run in ah the naked
scene but like but
properly naked i mean yes there's
nothing funnier than two naked bodies
slapping together
there's nothing sexy about it at all
it's funny to confess i wasn't really
looking at you i don't know
i remember you looking great
no i don't do naked for for sexy naked
only works for me in the funny but it
was great you said you don't do naked in
the series only in the funny yes
okay maybe that's it
yeah i don't know you know
on film on film no awkward anyway i mean
they're awkward yeah anyone put
you're having sex and you get reported
and you don't know you're being recorded
you my guess not that i've ever done
this i was gonna say this is a weird
story
is that you don't look good doing it no
oh you know